Hey.
Funny to see you there. I didn't, um, somebody joked
that I should get a lazyboy up here and see what happens.
No, um, I'm just trying to move lower and lower every week
and so next week we're gonna be sitting on the
floor I guess.
No, um, you may have noticed
that there's some construction going on,
some work on our building.
Uh, that's gonna be a couple more weeks out at least.
It was pretty extensive as we had a busted pipe
during the freeze.
I also had some work done on my knee this week
and so, uh, happened
to be a little more extensive than we originally thought.
So that means my timeline's a little longer than we thought
as well, but uh, it could be a lot worse.
Uh, the worst part is I have a big incision right on my
kneecap and so that makes it feel really good
to move it, bend it.
Um, that may be TMI to some of you, but that's okay.
We're real. This is a family.
So anyway, that's what we're at right now.
It could be a lot worse, but yeah.
So I can't let it hang is why I'm not standing
or why I'm not on that stool
that I've been the last few weeks.
So anyway, what a beautiful morning.
We're not here for any of that. That's not why we're here.
Um, we're here to stare into the face of God
and to to see his word, show us who he is,
to worship him in response and to to grow in our love
and to grow in our obedience to who he is
and what he's done for us.
And so to help us get to know him better, we've been going
through this series where we've been
calling first things first.
And so the first things that we need
to put into our theological jar first, that's
what we've been looking at the most important of our
doctrines, our beliefs, the core of what we believe.
And we're gonna review regularly just
so we get them in our heads.
So just remember they're, they're coming every week.
So remember the first one.
What was the first one of our big rocks
that we put in a couple weeks ago?
Revelation. Yeah, that's right. Alright, we're getting it.
Okay. So revelation that God has told us about himself.
Otherwise we wouldn't know much about who he is.
What was the second one? At the attributes of God.
This is what he's told us about himself,
what he is and who he is.
And so we put that in the jar.
Now the third one last week, this is the new one.
What did we look at last week? The Trinity?
Yeah, the three persons.
One God, equal person. Same essence.
That was the study of the Trinity, which was one
of the most hard, difficult to understand.
We know that, but it's also one of the most foundational
for our faith and it separates us from everybody else.
Biblical Christianity in this system is different
because of that.
We're gonna add one more rock today, of course,
this fourth rock, uh, another one
that could get us tripped up into all kinds
of different heresies along the way as well.
This rock is God the son, God the Son.
Now we could talk about God the Father,
God the Spirit like we talked to the Trinity,
but we're just gonna focus on God the Son,
what we call the incarnation Big word.
That means God took on flesh
and dwelled among us in order to save us.
That's the incarnation.
So we're gonna talk about that today and
and this mystery, it's a mystery like last week, it's not
as mind melting as the Trinity, but it's pretty close.
So there's gonna be stuff that we're gonna have
to really work through and talk about and look at.
But the question we have
to think about why this is such a mystery is how could
the God that we saw last week, all
that he is in his attributes, how could he retain all of
that yet also take on a body like
ours and not lose anything and
and be, how could he not be tainted by the fact
that he's taken on a body lesser?
That's the question of the incarnation.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna follow the track
of John one to help us try
to understand this a little bit better.
So go ahead and turn there with me if you would,
in your copy of God's revelation of Himself, his word.
We're gonna be in John one
and just follow that track a little bit
to help us understand some things about this incarnation.
Now this is one
of the most beautiful passages in all of scripture.
So I just wanna read it slowly
and I want it to sit on our souls for a little bit
as you just feel this passage
and what God has said to us here, John one, all the way down
through verse 18,
in the beginning was the word and the word was with God.
And the word was God. He was in the beginning with God.
All things were made through him.
And without him was not anything made
that was made in him was life.
And the life was the light of men.
The light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it.
There was a man sent from God whose name was John.
He came as a witness to bear witness about the light
that all might believe through him.
He was not the light
but came to bear witness about the light, the true light
which gives light to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
Yet the world did not know him.
He came to his own and his own people did not receive him,
but to all who did receive him, who believed in his name,
he gave the right to become children of God
who were born not of blood, nor of the will of the flesh,
nor of the will of man, but of God.
And the word became flesh and dwelt among us.
And we have seen His glory, glory as
of the only son from the Father full of grace and truth.
John bore witness about him and cried out.
This was he of whom I said, he who comes after me, ranks
before me because he was before me.
For from his fullness.
We have all received grace upon grace
For the law was given through Moses.
Grace and truth came through Jesus Christ.
No one has ever seen God, the only God
who is at the father's side.
He has made him known God.
What a beautiful passage of scripture.
What an incredible picture of
who you are and what you've done.
Lord, I pray that as we just soak in this passage
for a few minutes, that you would change our hearts.
You'd give us eyes to see you, our hearts
to be open, to receive you,
that we would be utterly changed by this doctrine,
this truth of God the Son incarnate,
thank you for this God, thank you for your word.
Thank you for changing us. Make us new even today.
Awaken us to this in Jesus' name. Amen.
And so not only is this passage so beautiful,
it's also rich theologically.
There's so much here
and so much of understanding of
who God is in the incarnation comes
right here from this passage.
It's highlighted here using this word,
son Christ progression.
So we're just gonna follow that, what
that looks like in this passage
and understand a little better.
So here's the first truth is that this word is
identified as the creator and the savior.
This word it talks about is identified
as the creator and the savior.
And so right away in verse one, we find that this,
this truth of the eternality of the word
and the divinity of this word is eternal
and divine.
It echoes Genesis one, right in the beginning,
the first few words in the beginning, same as Genesis one,
before time and space began was the word.
This means pre-existent.
That there was never a time where the word was not.
If you understand what I mean by that, the word has always.
And even before time began, the word was,
and it says the word was with God.
Now at first glance, let's just be clear.
That could mean there's separate entities.
You're with someone, right?
Except for the next phrase where it says,
and the word was God.
That's flashback to the trinity last week, right?
One God, three persons, same essence.
So the word is God, yet also was
with the Father.
So that you can see how this is confusing, yes,
but the same substance we also find out in verse four,
the word was life.
All things were made through him.
Nothing was made without this word.
Now again, this is a callback
to Genesis one in the beginning.
So he's talking about creation.
Do you recall how God created everything
back in Genesis one?
How did God do it? He spoke right?
And God said, let there be light.
And God said, let there be animals.
He spoke and created, he created through the word,
see that this is the idea we get right here.
All things were made through the word.
And so we're starting to build this theology
of understanding who this word is,
what this word even is.
Well, he briefly mentions John the Baptist role
proclaiming the savior.
It wasn't the same John who wrote this gospel, by the way.
They're different people.
He talks about John for a second,
but then we catch this light idea.
He says that John was a reflective light, that he was
bearing witness about the true light.
And so I was thinking about this. Here's a good example.
You, you can might, you might think about this
as like the sun and the the moon.
So when you go out at night, especially on a full moon or
or a large moon it, it may, it may look like
the moon is lighting up the night sky, right?
You walk outside, it's almost daylight at times.
It's so bright.
But does that moon have any light in itself?
Science class? No. Right?
It's just a big hunk of rock dust.
What it does is it reflects the light of the sun.
And so it appears to shine,
but it's really just reflecting the light.
Same for us, right?
That we are to be reflectors
of the true light.
Who gives light, who came into the world
as the light at that time.
So it's what our job is to be.
We're we're just a bunch
of big moons sitting around here, right?
Like it's just God's delight.
We are reflecting the light as we go into the world.
The problem here is
that not everyone has received the light.
John one says even his own family.
He says he came to his own.
That's talking about the Jewish people, the the people
that would have known him and should have known him.
He was born into that family.
They didn't recognize him, most people didn't.
He was even their creator
and they didn't have the spiritual eyes to see who he was.
Well sadly that still happens today, doesn't it?
People hear the gospel, they see God's good
and gracious news, but their eyes are closed to it.
It happens every day. They don't truly know God.
There might even be a semblance of religious activity.
They might be a good human being.
They might be a decent person, but they don't know God.
And again, did you see it here?
Verse 11 says, they did not receive him.
So the idea of that word receive the image
of it is like you receiving welcoming someone
as they are into your home.
So when you have someone come to your door, most people
don't know you, I'm not gonna let you in to receive
this word would be to say, I understand who you are.
I see who you are. Come on in as you are.
Verse 12, then repeats that phrase, adds a qualifier
to it says those who did receive him, it says
believed in his name.
That's the key. That's the condition of salvation.
Here it says belief
that you see the incarnate word as he is,
as the creator, as the light as God.
And you receive him as he is.
Meaning you give him his rightful place
as the master of your house.
Like not just a salesman coming to your door,
ringing the doorbell and you see him
and you're like, okay, come on.
Have a have a meal.
You see him as the savior, as the creator king.
And you say, come on in. You're in charge now.
That's what it means to receive this word
because you believe who he is and that's what makes you.
It says a reborn child of God. You can't be born into this.
Like just because your parents are Christians
does not make you a Christian.
You can't do this by your own effort.
You can't work your way into it.
It's only by God doing it in you.
It's what John one says.
And so I wonder, have you received him?
Have you believed in his name
and invited him in as the master of the house as he is
into your life to say You are in charge
so that I can be a part of your family.
Now, have you received
him this word?
Who is the savior? Have you received him?
Now so far we've only looked at this kind of vague
word, God language.
That's what John one starts with.
But verse 14, notice marks a shift in the passage to
son, father language.
Still the same characters, just how we meet them.
Look again at verse 14.
And the word, this word we've been talking about,
the word became flesh and dwelt among us.
And we've seen His glory.
Glory as of the only son from the Father full
of grace and truth.
So the eternal word here is signified as the son
by taking on flesh.
So the word that we were just kind of aware of is now said
to be the son
and shows that by taking on flesh again, this is
what we call the incarnation,
that God the Son put on a flesh suit.
Now here is where we easily drift into the ditches
of heresy on both sides of this.
Like you're driving a road
and you got ditches on both sides.
We're trying to avoid those
and people have done this for 2000 years,
fallen into all kinds of things.
And so we need to learn how to speak well
of the incarnation just like
we did with the Trinity last week.
We've gotta have some good language.
And so we, we put what we've figured out to be the best just
by going back into the church.
Fathers old people
who understood this worked on it for a long time.
We put it on your notes. Here's a great definition
in response to heresies.
Were popping up all over the place.
This group of church leaders got together at Caldon in
4 51 ad.
So over 1500 years ago to come up with a solid foundation
and definition of this incarnation we're talking about.
So it'll be on the screen, it's on your notes.
Listen to this talking about God the Son, one
and the same son, our Lord Jesus Christ.
The same perfect in Godhead and also perfect in manhood.
Truly God and truly man of a reasonable soul
and body consubstantial that word means one substance
with the Father according to the Godhead and consubstantial.
One substance with us according
to the manhood means he's truly human
in all things like unto us without sin, though
begotten before all ages of the Father,
according to the Godhead.
And in these latter days for us
and for our salvation, born of the virgin Mary, according
to the manhood, one in the same Christ son, Lord,
only begotten to be acknowledged in two natures
incon, confusingly, unchangeable, indivisibly inseparably.
The distinction of nature's being by no means taken away
by the union, but rather the property
of each nature being preserved
and concurring in one person, one subsistence, not parted
or divided into two persons, but one in the same son.
The only begotten God, the Word the Lord Jesus Christ.
Lots of big words there.
I think I might have even drifted off while reading it.
So I get, it's hard to understand,
but this is how complicated this can get, right?
When we try to understand God taking on flesh, like right
yet, here's the key elements you can pick through
that one for years.
But the key elements are the fact that the eternal son was
and is God perfectly
and man perfectly,
truly sinlessly.
Yet he still one substance with the Father
plus because of that,
it means he has two natures in one person,
fully, perfectly.
That's something that the theologians have termed
hypostatic union.
Throw that one out at your next birthday party, right?
Hypostatic union.
It means two natures in one being, one essence.
So here's okay, trying to simplify this.
Let me give you just a simple way to say this.
Think of it this way. God the Son
merely took on another nature, a human nature.
Like if you're gonna baseline it, level it out,
God the Son took on another nature, a human one.
Again, it's a mystery though, a difficult mystery,
which is why people fall into the ditches.
I wanna give you a couple examples of
how people have fallen into the ditches over the years
in this doctrine of the incarnation, trying to explain this
probably right hearted, but
but just getting off track in some ways.
Some would say Jesus only appeared to be human.
He was kind of some ghost. He wasn't really human.
We thought he was, but,
but that that would deny the true humanity of Jesus,
which means he couldn't then die for us and be our savior.
I, last week I mentioned Arianism, which says
that Jesus was created by God.
Well that can't be true
because this just said he existed from before time began.
But, but that heresy's still alive
and well all over the place with Mormonism
and Jehovah's Witnesses.
Here's others. They would say that Jesus was two nature's,
yes, but two persons and
and rather than one person, even to the point
that he had two minds.
Well when you think about that, that would be competition
somehow happening inside him,
which we call schizophrenia even today, right?
Like so there's this I that can't be true of him.
Two minds, no Still.
Others would say that the divine
and human nature somehow went into the Cuisinart blender
and came out as one, a different form of nature somehow
a third type of nature.
Now, I like the fact that we want to try to keep unity here,
but we also have to keep the two natures separate, divine
and human still.
Others say that Christ only had one nature
or he had only one will that still denies that he's both God
and man Here, here's even more like you can see
how far we can get off track, right?
Some people, we even say that, that Joseph
and Mary had this, they they conceived this baby
and that the, the God the son then just overtook the baby
whenever the baby was conceived
or even that, that he found some guy named Jesus 30
years later and overtook that body
and became Jesus this son that we know
or even that that Jesus, yeah, was kind of something.
But then at the baptism is when he became God the Son
again, we're trying to understand this,
but you can't explain it apart from
what God's word has just said to us.
These are all heresies,
But there's one that we might even drift into inadvertently,
but, but it's done by misinterpreting scripture.
It's Philippians chapter two which says
that Christ emptied himself.
It's what we call the kenosis theory.
That word kenosis is the Greek word for empty.
And we say that in a way that that implies that
for somewhere in some way he's not God anymore.
He's he emptied himself of his divinity so
that he could become man.
Now, now we have to be very clear about this.
When God the Son stepped out of eternity
and took on flesh, he did not lose anything.
That's right. Right?
You hear that he did not lose anything.
He didn't set aside his divinity in any way.
If we start getting down that road, we're walking into a lot
of those things we just talked about.
Because you remember Colossians two, nine,
we spent like 20 years in Colossians last year, right?
It seems so Colossians two nine, the whole fullness
of deity dwells in him bodily.
It's in Jesus the whole fullness of deity.
So here again, the healthier way to think about it is
that God the Son, merely added on humanity.
He didn't lose anything, set anything aside.
He just took on something. He didn't change in any way.
He just set aside what we might think the full glory
of sitting at the throne of God forever.
He set that aside, humbled himself,
became a servant.
Even to the point of shameful death on a cross.
That's what he set aside, that he emptied himself
of a glorified position so
that he could come live in obedience, die on the cross,
accomplish redemption.
There's nothing about his divinity that changed.
He didn't set anything aside.
He set aside this position, which we read Philippians two.
He did empty himself of that position.
But what happened next? He goes back to the position again.
So it was merely that glory that he was longing to receive.
Again, John 17, he's talking about this idea of saying, God,
I need that position back.
Glorify me again in that sense.
And he did through this humbling exaltation.
So this idea, again, I'm gonna say it all the time,
incarnation's really hard.
Yes, but it is essential.
I love how it was said that God,
the Son taking on flesh will remain for eternity.
The most profound miracle
and the most profound mystery in all the universe.
Some miracle and a mystery.
Yet we can learn to speak well of it.
We can understand it so we can grow and love.
And so we're, we're walking this track.
Now we've seen the word. Now we've seen the Son.
It's developing. Watch this.
Now let's go back and read John one 14 through 18.
It's continuing to develop this watch
the word became flesh dwelled among us.
We've seen his glory.
Glory as of the only son from the Father full
of grace and truth.
John bore witness cried out.
This was he of whom I said He comes after me, ranks
before me 'cause he was before me for from his fullness.
We've all received grace. Upon grace.
The law was given through Moses.
Grace and truth came through. Here we go, Jesus Christ.
No one's ever seen God,
the only God who's at the father's side.
He has made him known.
So one thing that John clarifies for us here is
that this son, there's a relationship that's begotten
with the Father.
You don't really see it here. It's in the background.
Greek word. It's the begottens.
Now you saw that when I read the definition
earlier, the creed.
Now you've probably heard that word before
because it's in the verse
that most people have memorized if they're at all
around church, John three 16, not in every translation,
but the King James version says it.
You know the the one that's on that sign
behind the field goal at every football game.
No, I put the Steelers up there.
That's an honor of B deal by the way.
Uh, sorry that they're losing in that scene, but it's okay.
Um, but John three 16, right?
The one that most people memorize first in the King James.
I remember Awana growing up. I remember it this way.
For God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should not perish
but have everlasting life.
I dunno why when I say that I feel like I need
to say it in a British accent or something.
Whosoever believeth that sounded more Boston. I don't know.
Uh, okay, but what does begotten even mean?
Like we say it but we don't even know what it means.
Well the word itself means to give rise to
or to bring about.
Often referring to a mother and a father begetting a child.
Again, we don't talk like that very often,
but here in the original Greek language,
the word monogenist, it's translated as only, that's
where you see it in John one only or only son
or only begotten John three 16.
So when we're talking about the trinity
and the forgottenness of the sun,
it does not mean created.
We saw that in the nice scene creed last week.
Begotten not made.
What it's talking about, and this is hard,
but it's talking about the relationship eternally
between the two persons
of the Godhead we're talking about here, the father
and the son.
There's a begotten
to the son from the father.
Again, not created, always existed in three persons,
but there's a relationship.
That's what this is talking about.
It's John one 18 right here.
It says, no one has ever seen God.
The only God that's the begotten word we just said.
Who's at the father's side? He has made him known.
So this is the idea the son is begotten.
The only meaning there's a relationship
that's a high level.
But, but that's the idea for us.
As we understand this,
we can know nothing about the three persons
of the Trinity apart from God revealing it in his word.
And this is how he said it.
The Father and the Son, there's a relationship there to us.
They're identical, but he says no,
actually the son is begotten.
The spirit is proceeding from,
you could say it that way as well.
There's a relationship in this trinity.
So the word of God is the son of God, third
or second person of the trinity.
But who then? So, so we're trying
to come down the levels here.
Who do we then meet this son to be?
Who does John say was before him?
Verse 17 says, Jesus Christ.
So he's tying all this together, right?
The word to the Son, to the Christ, this eternal word
of God, the Son of God took on flesh in his mission
to save us and we now know him
as the Lord and Savior Jesus Christ.
This is all part of the eternal nature of God.
Finally showing up to us in Jesus.
That's the verse 18, only God who makes God known.
That's the one who gives us grace upon grace.
That's the one who shows us God's glory.
And this is why all these rocks tied together.
The only all that trinity stuff from last week.
That's how Jesus himself can say in John 14,
whoever has seen me has seen the Father.
He says, I am in the Father and the Father is in me.
Jesus, if he's just a man that doesn't work.
But Jesus, the son of God, the word of God.
That's how it all works out together.
That's why we talk about God,
the Son taking on flesh in the incarnation.
We say He just added on a nature. He didn't lose anything.
He didn't let anything go.
He added on this human nature for us.
And here's why this is really important, because
otherwise Luke eight doesn't make any sense
Unless we say it this way.
Listen to what this says.
One day Jesus got into a boat with his disciples
and he said to them, let's go across
to the other side of the lake.
And so they set out and as he sa, as they sailed,
he fell asleep and a windstorm came down on the lake
and they were filling with water and they were in danger.
And they went and woke him saying, master,
master we're perishing.
And he awoke and rebuked the wind and the raging waves
and they ceased and there was a calm.
He said to them, where's your faith? And they were afraid.
And they marveled saying to one another who then is this,
that he commands even winds and water and they obey him.
That scene shows us the two natures in Christ, right?
You've got his human nature
where he fully identifies worth us, where he's
so tired he falls asleep in a storm.
Now this boat, not like a cruise ship
where you're down in the bowels of it
and you're safe, like this was an open,
simple boat fishing vessel
and this thing, just imagine you got wind and waves
and thunder and, and he's just, he's just sleeping.
Like how do you water flashes? That's how tired he was.
Yet notice his divine nature is not diminished
in any way because he's God.
He stood up, said a word to the wind
and the waves and they stopped.
He spoke, right?
So human nature like us,
divine nature
God, who is this?
They asked. They were stunned. Well, we know who he is.
The second person of the trinity, the eternal word of God,
the eternal son of God who took on flesh
as Jesus Christ to save us.
That's who He is. And listen, that is
what brings us the most benefit.
That's what brings God the most glory.
Because verse 14 says,
the word became flesh and dwelt among us.
We've seen his glory.
Glory is the only son from the Father full
of grace and truth.
That grace and truth is what comes from God.
It comes through Jesus Christ. That's who we know him to be.
This Messiah, he's glorified as salvation. Something.
The law through through Moses could never do only
through God's grace, which remember is undeserved favor.
Like you get a gift at your birthday.
You don't deserve that. God just gives it to you.
That's grace and truth, which is the ultimate standard
of what is right and wrong.
That he himself is the standard of how things ought to be.
How we ought to be. And here's the problem.
When we hear truth, we quickly figure out we don't measure
up to that standard of truth.
Right? He came full of truth.
If we broken one of his commands, we've broken all of them
and we're guilty of it.
That's why we need not only truth, we need grace.
And listen, if, if our biggest need was information,
God would have sent an educator.
If our biggest need was technology,
God would've sent a scientist.
If our biggest need was finances,
God would've sent an economist.
If our biggest need was pleasure,
God would've sent an entertainer.
But because our biggest need was
forgiveness, God sent a savior.
Amen. The Son in the flesh
who would truly take on our humanity so
that he could feel every temptation that we feel
yet remain sinless in it.
So he could be the adequate sacrifice as the bridge
between divinity and humanity to cover our sin
and make a way to be both
the at toner
and the atonement, right?
He is the one who gives salvation
and he is the means to get salvation.
God and man in one. No one else could have done that.
Only God himself can provide it.
That's what the word of God came to do.
That's what the Son came to do.
'cause Jesus was not merely a good man.
He was not merely a good example.
He was not merely a good teacher, a good prophet
what every everybody else would say about him.
No, he was and is the son of God who took on flesh
to make God known to us, to to show us
the love of God better than anything else ever could. Amen.
Hall, For God so loved the world
that he gave his son.
It's because of his heart, his love.
Yet remember John one says, we must receive him.
We must believe in his name.
That's the only way you can become a child of God, a part
of this eternal family of God.
It's through believing.
And listen, if you have not received him
yet, what's holding you back?
This God is not some force out there.
He's the God who draws near,
not just kind of close.
He draws near to say, I came to you.
I took on flesh for you.
He's not far from each one of us.
Acts 17 says, receive him.
But if you have received Him, church,
if you have received him, then my prayer today has been
that we would be reawaken to the greatness of our God
and Savior, that God would do this
all this for us.
Is that not stunning?
Well, I think we should sing quickly in light of this.
And so I'm gonna invite every, get them out here as quickly
as possible and the 15 people it takes
to get me off the stage here.
So but, but this is the idea, right?
Two Corinthians 5 21, he made him
to be sin who knew no sin.
So that in him we might become the righteousness of God.
That Christ came, the son of God came so
that we could be made new.
And it's his merit, his effort, his salvation
that makes the way for us.